SPEAKER: Welcome to Google Cloud
Drawing Board, where we doodle
our way through the Cloud.
Today's topic--
What is Cloud CDN?
This video is divided
into chapters.
Watch the full
video or skip ahead
to a new section of your choice.
Whatever your app or
website is, chances
are that your users
are distributed
across different
locations and are not
necessarily close to
where your servers are.
This means the requests travel
across the public internet
through long distances, leading
to inconsistent and frustrating
user experiences.
That's where Cloud CDN comes in.
Cloud CDN is a content
delivery network
that accelerates your
web and video content
delivery by using
Google's Global Edge
Network to bring content as
close to the user as possible.
As a result, the
latency, cost, and load
on your backend servers is
reduced, making it easier
to scale to millions of users.
Let's consider an app to
understand how this works.
When a user makes a request
to your website or app,
the request is routed to the
closest Google Edge Node.
We have all 120 of these for
fast and reliable traffic flow.
Then, to the global
HTTP(S) load balancer,
to the backend, or the origin.
From there, with
Cloud CDN enabled,
we'll serve the content
directly from cache.
Cache is nothing but a group of
servers that store and manage
cacheable content so that
future requests for that content
can be solved faster.
The cached content is a
copy of cachable content
that is stored on
your origin servers,
typically including web assets
like JavaScript, CSS, images,
and videos.
Cloud CDN can automatically
cache this content
with just a single checkbox,
using the recommended cache
modes to cache all
static content.
If you need more control, you
can direct Cloud seeding CDN
by setting HTTP headers
on your responses.
And you can also force
all content to be cached.
Just know that this ignores
the private, no-store,
or no-cache directives in
cache control response headers.
When the request is
received by Cloud CDN,
it looks for the cached content
using the cache key, which
is typically the URI.
But you can customize
this cache key
to remove protocol
posts or query strings.
For the user's request,
if a cached response
is found in Cloud CDN
cache, the response
is retrieved from cache
and sent to the user.
This is called a cache hit.
When a cache hit
occurs, Cloud CDN
looks at the content
byte's cache key
and responds
directly to the user,
shortening the round trip time
and saving the origin server
from having to
process the request.
The first time that a piece
of content is requested,
the Cloud CDN can't fulfill
the request from the cache
because it doesn't
have it there.
This is called a cache miss.
When a cache miss
occurs, the Cloud CDN
might attempt to get the
content from the nearby cache.
If the nearby cache
has the content,
it sends it to the first cache
by using cache-to-cache fill.
Otherwise, it just
sends the request
through the origin server.
The maximum lifetime
of the object in cache
is defined by the TTLs,
or time to live values,
set by the cache directives
from each a HTTP response,
or cache modes.
When the TTL has expired, the
content is evicted from catch.
Now, how do you use Cloud CDN?
You can set up Cloud CBN through
GCloud Command Line interface,
Could Consol, or the APIs.
Since Cloud CBN leverages Google
Cloud global external HTTP(S)
load balancers to
provide routing, health
checking, and
Anycast support, it
can be enabled by easily
checking a box while setting up
the backends or the origins.
Cloud CDN makes it even easier
to solve web and media content
using Google Cloud Storage.
You just upload your content to
a bucket, set up load balancer,
and enable caching.
And if you are like
many of our customers, ,
you probably have services that
are on-prem or in other clouds.
To enable these
hybrid architectures,
Cloud CDN and HTTP(S)
load balancing
also support external backends.
Let's get into the
underlying details now.
Global Anycast IPs provide
single IP for global reach.
It allows Google Cloud to
round users to the nearest edge
cache automatically and avoid
relying on the DNS propagation
delays that can
impact availability.
It also supports HTTP end-to-end
and quick protocol from cache
to cache.
QUIC is a
multiplex-to-stream transport
over UDP, which
reduces latency, making
it ideal for lossy
mobile networks.
That brings me to security.
Data is encrypted at rest and in
transit from Google Cloud load
balancing to backend, supporting
an end-to-end encrypted
experience.
You can programmatically
sign URLs and cookies
to limit video segment access
to all authorized users only.
The signature is
validated at the CDN Edge
and the request that
should not get through
is blocked right there.
On a broader level,
you can enable SSL
for free using
Google managed certs.
Now, to summarize, use Cloud
CDN to improve performance
and reduce serving costs
for regularly accessed
content by automatically
caching static content
with a click of a button.
Want to learn more
about Cloud CDN?
Check out cloud.google.com/cdn.